[Música]
carmen paz que este castro
[Aplausos]
buenos días gente o les vamos a contar
una cosa pero si sois conscientes vale
pero yo soy del 98 si quiere decir que
cuando yo aterricé en este mundo había
esto estos móviles quien tenía un nokia
por aquel entonces o unos cuantos unos
cuantos y ahora quien tiene un bloqueo
uno por ahí perdido wow es que fijaos en
tan sólo 20 años cómo han cambiado las
cosas es brutal
[Música]
antes de lo que crees tus hijos dejarán
de jugar
así que con esto estamos viviendo una
auténtica revolución porque cuando yo
nací no existía ni el iphone ni facebook
ni twitter ni spotify ni amazon
instagram mier bien vi newberg ni
siquiera 15 dios mío pero como podías
vivir sin tener madre mía o sea esto es
una verdadera revolución bueno la
llamada revolución emocional porque
porque por primera vez estamos viviendo
una situación de nuestros valores
estamos dejando espacio para esa
dimensión más emocional habéis visto la
cantidad de gente joven que está
cambiando las cosas y precisamente hoy
os vengo a hablar de eso y como los
jóvenes tenemos una visión completamente
diferente completamente opuesta en la
forma de concebir las relaciones el
concepto de privacidad el concepto de
propiedad privada el ocio absolutamente
todo y porque hablo de reducción de los
valores porque nos hemos puesto
profundos y nos hemos dado cuenta de que
no es cuestión de tener de que es
cuestión de ser
no es cuestión de tener coche casa
pareja una categoría social no no nos
hemos quedado con eso nos hemos quedado
con algo más profundo vamos a ver
señores ahora mismo hablar de productos
arcaico si tenemos servicios podemos
vivir una experiencia tampoco no hemos
de conocimiento total tenemos aquí en el
bolsillo los móviles en el cual podemos
expresar cualquier dato a golpe de clic
es más importante desarrollarse a uno
mismo como persona es más importante la
actitud las habilidades las capacidades
tanto es así que si os ponemos a pensar
qué millennial conocéis que se compre
una casa o un coche eso ya es de viaje
unos eso ya a veces es impensable lo
tenemos otras alternativas y
precisamente porque porque nos hemos
dado cuenta de que las cosas son de
quien las disfruta
también en relación con esto hemos
sacado partido a todo lo que tiene que
ver con la economía colaborativa y tanto
es así que no solamente es que vayamos
al coworking si nos pongamos modernos
sino que encima por compartir ahora
mismo compartimos hasta la pareja porque
ya no está el raro hablar de conceptos
como el poliamor que no es tan raro
hablar de orientación relacional ahora
no hablamos de tener pareja como una
etiqueta a la que nos aferramos sino que
nos centramos más en el crecer juntos
junto a otra persona tampoco buscamos
tener un título universitario hay cuanta
titulitis qué tontería hacia lo
importante es que sabes hacer hay que
quedarse con eso no señores y
precisamente por eso hemos conseguido
darle la vuelta al concepto de trabajo
vale no no no no no os equivoquéis con
esto no me refiero a que nos hagamos
todos youtubers instagramers influencers
no
mucho mucho mucho más trascendental
por primera vez pues ahora mismo hemos
puesto de moda el ser emprendedor el
freelance pero sobre todo hablamos de
conceptos como es el concepto de la
marca personal de quién soy yo qué
capacidades tengo y cómo las pongo al
servicio de los demás wow qué
trascendental
nos parece esta es una oportunidad que
no han vivido a nuestros padres hemos
dicho que no va a calentar la silla a
ese modelo de estar pues eso desde las 7
de la mañana hasta las cinco de la tarde
repitiendo lo mismo por primera vez
podemos ya no es un lujo no el poder
alinear nuestro propósito vital nuestros
valores con nuestra actividad económica
poder desarrollarnos como personas del
trabajo
y cada vez yo veo más evidencias de esto
de hecho unos meses atrás tuve la gran
experiencia de vivir una startup weekend
para quien no lo conoce es un evento en
el cual los últimos 150 200 locos con el
propósito de crear una startup en 54
horas o sea un fin de semana
enclaustrado como veis y claro para mí
fue una experiencia totalmente
transformadora porque claro te das
cuenta de que es es un sitio ese es un
evento que te da ese espacio de conectar
con los demás de unir a gente de
diferentes nacionalidades de diferentes
edades de diferentes campos del saber
solamente con el propósito de construir
no de hacer algo en lo que realmente
creemos y realmente vamos en tiempo
récord y claro ahí te das cuenta de que
ejecutar cualquier proyecto es un camino
hacia adentro no en relación con esta
revolución te das cuenta de que si no
eres seguro de ti mismo no vas a saber
vender tu idea si no eres capaz de dar
alas a tu equipo no vas a conseguir
llegar a ese objetivo y precisamente el
equipo que tuve para mí fue un ejemplo
de todo esto un ejemplo de querer
compartir de querer aportar valor y me
llenó de emoción el darme cuenta de que
ese compartir ya lo hemos adoptado como
propio y forma parte de nuestra esencia
como especie humana
gente que me recuerda esto todos los
días son mis chavales mis chigüín keys o
sea de las mejores cosas que me ha
pasado hace tres años tengo la gran
suerte de entrenar a un equipo de
robótica a chavales de entre 10 y 13
años que es que vamos lo cuestionan todo
y te derriban todos los esto todos los
estereotipos
y que también me demuestran que cuando
das ese espacio das esa oportunidad para
crear sin prejuicios y con todas y donde
de alguna manera y incentivas ideas a
esa su creatividad porque yo solamente
yo construyo con ellos y solamente
pretendo acompañarles llegar a su
respeto pero yo no soy ninguna autoridad
porque quiero que ellos son los
protagonistas quiero que ellos
construyan y hagan su propia verdad a
partir de ese camino
señores no es ninguna novedad todo esto
está sabemos que está de moda las
llamadas de esquí los estos valores de
solidaridad de empatía de trabajo en
equipo de cooperación si es que la
teoría no sabemos todos lo que quizás no
sabemos lo que quizás lo tenemos tan en
cuenta es que la manera en la que los
exigimos la que el siglo 21 nos exige
tener a estos valores adoptados como
propios hace que cambie el paradigma del
consumidor porque porque al igual que
somos exigentes con nosotros mismos
somos exigentes con las marcas mis
amigas por ejemplo ya lo consumen
maquillaje que texto animales porque no
les identifica no no va acorde con su
forma de ver las cosas
y tanto es así que al final lo que vamos
a exigir a las marcas es precisamente
eso es una transferencia es una calidad
es una serie de valores que está que son
que están un poco alineados con este
cambio de paradigma porque lo que yo
tengo en común con un ruso con un
esquimal con un estadounidense con un
americano es precisamente eso los
valores el rechazo hacia ideas como
pueden ser la corrupción como puede ser
la inseguridad como podría ser tantas
cosas y el aprecio por ese confort por
esa seguridad por esa calidad y por una
serie de valores que tenemos intrínsecos
como propios que nos definen como raza
humana y por primera vez nos podemos
entender mejor entre nosotros porque yo
a través de redes sociales a través de
youtube
puedo ver cómo es la realidad de un
chino o de un pro de un estadounidense y
acercarme más a ellos y abrir más la
mente
estamos a la época de converger a los
suelos a los que nos guste big bang
theory as que les guste la física que
ahora mismo está de moda lo del tema de
la teoría del todo de unificar también
nos está pasando como sociedad también
se está pasando a nivel global porque
porque al final los valores es las
emociones son ese hilo conductor que nos
define como raza entonces vamos a estar
cada vez más cerca de una moral de un
patrón de conducta como vivimos la
globalización en la cual podamos
conectar con cada persona del mundo sea
como sea
os quiero hacer una pregunta no sé si
conocéis quién conoce esta sala diez
veces
bueno unos cuantos otra pregunta qué es
esto así que me debes responder todos
quién compra razón
bueno no es novedad no abajo le está
cambiando el mundo y ya empiezas con él
y precisamente por esto por la parte de
los valores esta fotografía es de al
poco tiempo de nacer y yo tenía
solamente un año
fijaos amazon pintado ahí en un roto lo
cutre no con un modo graffiti y no había
nada está casi vacío no es que un mil
del hombre el hombre esté bueno en este
momento la empresa amazon valía 30 mil
millones de dólares y no hacía
ostentación de nada porque porque él
pensaba que al fin y al cabo todos los
recursos todo todas las energías tenían
que ir siempre enfocadas en lo
importante en el cliente en aportar
valor fijaos qué ejemplo de humildad yo
siempre me cuesta ejemplo porque la
gente pues cuando cuando cuento esto
cuando hablamos de valores la gente dice
que no ahy tontería que incluso esto
esto no es real no y claro cuando te das
cuenta de que el paradigma empresarial
está recogiendo esta realidad ya ya es
otra cosa
es curioso pero todos estos valores de
ser paciente de innovar de trabajar en
equipo es lo que ha llegado a situar a
jeff bezos como el hombre más rico del
mundo
son valores que además tradicionalmente
han sido femeninos pero que en realidad
tenemos todos y es nuestra
responsabilidad exaltar los porque
precisamente por el nuevo tipo de
consumidor que estamos gestando entramos
en la era de la responsabilidad personal
y ponen a la mujer en un papel
determinante en este nuevo tipo de
sociedad con un liderazgo que tienen
interese con ellas por su forma de
comunicarse por la empatía que tienen
por pues por cultural o esos valores que
nos han atribuido desde pequeñas
de hecho no sé si lo habéis pensado pero
como decía javier sirven todas
absolutamente todos los asistentes de
voz son mujeres
wow veis por dónde voy qué casualidad
y es que precisamente es una causa que
nos duele a todos a hombres ya mujeres y
que nos hace movilizarnos a nivel macro
tanto es así que aquí en madrid fuimos
un ejemplo para españa y para el resto
de europa y del mundo pero conseguimos
taponar la capital capitales de
provincias por una causa que es súper
humana no y que habla también de esta
revolución de cómo nos movilizamos de
forma exponencial
desde la perspectiva macro histórica
también tiene sentido hablar de una
revolución
yo pienso en la revolución francesa la
revolución francesa
al final hablaba de libertad igualdad
fraternidad y gracias a ella hoy en día
tenemos una democracia
esta revolución no vino sola vino al
tiempo de la revolución industrial
porque porque todos los cambios que se
producen a nivel ideológico casi siempre
van unidos con una parte económica
cambiamos el modo de producción
cambiamos la forma socialmente y con
ello cambiamos nuestra mentalidad
no es ninguna novedad que estamos
sumergidos en una revolución digital
hemos cambiado la forma de acceder a la
información e incluso todo lo que está
todo lo que está en diferentes campos no
en educación en sanidad en todos los
sectores económicos
y con ello va a venir la revolución
emocional la revolución emocional no es
otra cosa que la exaltación de nuestra
dimensión más humana en forma de
plantear las organizaciones en forma de
plantear el trabajo
en cada decisión de compra que tomamos
que lastimamos como un voto hacia qué
realidad queremos qué empresa nos
identifica qué empresa nos identifica y
tantos así señores que lo siento mucho
pero toda empresa sin un papel social
está condenada a desaparecer porque
somos exigentes porque es lo que nos une
y porque realmente por fin estamos
dejando espacio para esa dimensión que
nos define
y con esto vuelvo al principio lo
estamos gestando lo estamos empezando a
vivir gracias a que nosotros los jóvenes
tenemos una manera diferente de plantear
todo relaciones concepto de propiedad
privada concepto de ocio yo no sé
vosotros pero me siento súper agradecida
súper agradecida de estar viviendo este
momento histórico en este espacio y
tiempo porque tenemos oportunidades para
formarnos porque tenemos una serie de
posibilidades que para nuestros padres
eran impensables y que nos ponen a
nosotros como agentes del cambio estáis
preparados
muchísimas gracias
[Música]
y